are you sick of all the fees and the
hassle of having a checking account at a
big bank check out our sponsor current
using the link below I'll tell you more
about them at the end of the video as
many of you may know I've mentioned I've
been listening to the Howard Stern Show
for more than 20 years and he has had
recently increasingly interesting
comments about Donald Trump including
this week and the the back story is that
Donald Trump and Howard Stern sort of
used to be acquaintances I don't know
that I'd say friends but Donald Trump
would regularly appear on Howard Stern's
show for years he would say many
outrageous things he would rate women on
scales from one to ten you know all
sorts of different stuff they don't talk
anymore Howard Stern vociferous Lee
supported Hillary Clinton in 2016 and
from what I gather Trump and Howard
Stern have not spoken since that time
and Howard Stern had an interesting take
about the relationship between Trump and
his own supporters when he did a show
earlier this week on Sirius XM radio and
the gist of it is that Trump supporters
are mostly people that Trump despises
here bearing in mind that Donald Trump
grew up rich in New York and his
supporters overwhelmingly are the types
of folks that Trump would never want at
mar-a-lago or at his own hotels or
around him or whatever the case may be
that that is the constituency that has
disproportionately made up
Trump's base rural white Midwestern and
southern Americans for example I think
you get the gist of it but not doesn't
apply to everybody but let's check out
the comments and then discuss the oddity
in all of this is the people Trump
despises most love him the most think
about it
the the the people who are voting for
Trump for the most part they're not
people he wants oh my god he won't even
know I'm in a hotel be disgusted with
them he doesn't want to go look at
mar-a-lago see if there's any people
that look like you I'm talking to you in
the audience that the Trump voter who
you know idolizes the guy he despises
you
despises you you're someone to grab by
the [ __ ] if you're hot
I know Donnell I know him very well
and I don't hate Donald I hate you for
voting for him I don't hate Donald but I
don't do this thing I hate you from
voting for him for not having an int and
intelligence and I name it let's see
what's going on with the coronavirus not
able to see what the Justice Department
is doing I hate you
don't want you here I want to build a
wall and throw you the
I do I'm for a walk
the mad chicken for you
that's how I feel now don't call me and
start arguing with me Howard you're a
jerk you're a lip [ __ ] or whatever it is
you call I ain't no lip [ __ ] trust me
I'm hardly a liberal
hardly you have no idea how no
non-liberal I am this is pretty spot-on
in some ways in the sense that they just
don't get it it is true that the Trump
voter typically just doesn't get it but
this is not unique to Donald Trump and I
think it bears a little more exploration
and to understand this you have to think
about personal versus in-group
priorities personal versus in-group
frameworks the 2010 Tea Party is an
example that I've talked about before
social psychologist Jonathan Hite talked
about this we interviewed him on the
program year or so ago maybe a little
longer and he's written about this
extensively he wrote about it in the
book the righteous mind which if you
don't have to agree with everything that
Jonathan height writes but and I don't
agree with it 100% but he writes about
this extensively and the gist is when
you look at individual versus group
framing there is a very long history of
people acting in ways that don't seem to
be optimized at their individual level
but are optimized for their group and as
a result they perceive that it will
confer benefits to them and the best way
to think about it is with an example
um you look at the 2010 Tea Party all
right 2010 Tea Party ran on lower taxes
for the rich don't tread on me right so
lower government regulations lower
government involvement don't regulate
business nearly as much essentially
allow more pollution lower fuel
efficiency standards more oil drilling
fewer welfare benefits and social
programs you look at who was
overwhelmingly supporting the Tea Party
you look at the districts where the Tea
Party candidate won sometimes against an
incumbent sort of more traditional
Republican it was overwhelmingly people
who were never going to be rich and
benefit from those tax cuts for the rich
whose taxes weren't going to go down if
Tea Partiers got their way who live in
places that would be ravaged by the very
industrial pollution that the tea party
would have allowed by eliminating
government regulations and taking this
lazy fair more libertarian approach so
you might be able to just simply say
we're on the Left we we we understand
what these dumb people don't these are
just stupid people trick
into voting against their own best
interests and that is so the wrong
approach they may have been tricked but
it's not that they don't understand the
policies of the Tea Party they
understand in many cases what the
policies are they've identified that
those are the policies that their group
favors even if they don't immediately
see or believe that at any point they
will personally benefit they believe
that there will be a sort of
trickle-down benefit because this is
what their group wants and that is why
they are voting for these policies by
voting for the Tea Party they may not
even know why baby not realised that
their group has actually been taken over
by elites who want to use them as a tool
to achieve what's good for them rather
than for the actual voters who are just
gonna get peanuts or crumbs but they
understand the policies and in many
cases they've identified the policies as
this is what our team or our group wants
and I'm going to vote with the orthodoxy
of the group I'm a part of apply that to
the Trump voter and you see that there's
a similarity in many cases we've
categorized Trump voters before some of
them don't actually understand what
Trump runt ran on they don't they have
no clue what the policies are or they
don't understand them could be because
of cognitive limitations it could be
people who lack education and critical
thinking skills simply people who don't
watch the news and just sort of like
herd vote for Donald Trump there's
people who voted for Trump because they
have a limited understanding of the
facts but a lot of Trumpets
do understand the policies of Trump and
even if they don't see how it helps them
specifically they're part of the group
except that the people really in Trump's
group which is what Howard Stern points
out are people who hang out at
mar-a-lago and a lot of these Trump
supporters I would say the overwhelming
majority are people that free a politics
Trump would never be associated with
would be seen as would be seeing as
people that are fundamentally beneath
him most Trump voters are people Trump
wouldn't be caught dead with except as
part of a photo-op or rally now that
he's a politician now where I disagree
with Howard Stern is this entire you
know I hate his support
orders for voting for him and their
their dumb that's an understandable
visceral reaction particularly when you
see the way that Donald Trump's
presidency has ravaged so many aspects
of society and culture and the economy
and the u.s. standing around the world
and on and on and on but as a practical
matter it falls under the umbrella of
what I'd call vote shaming and it's it's
plenty interesting to do for a broadcast
show and it's it's compelling and
salacious but I don't think it's a good
way to get people to reconsider their
votes now at the same time I don't think
that Trump is going to be defeated by
convincing his supporters not to vote
for him I've said before I don't believe
that that's the strategy I think the
strategy is mobilize your key
constituencies and get people out to
vote who already agree with you but that
being said I don't see any particular
advantage did the approach of if you
voted for Trump you're dumb and I hate
you for it certainly we should
acknowledge that we believe it was a
mistake it was the wrong decision but I
don't know that there's much to gain
from this general umbrella term of what
I would call vote shaming as much as it
might be the obvious visceral emotional
reaction on our side we're going to keep
talking about this and the other stories
from today's show on the David Pakman
show instagram at david pakman show also
yesterday on my Instagram I showed
everybody my cukes
I have a whole bunch of cucumber plants
which I thought were dead I thought
these seeds are dead these aren't going
to germinate I've got no sprouts but I
have sprouts now and I showed my sprouts
to everybody yesterday you can check it
out on my Instagram at David Pakman
nothing better than a coronavirus
Victory Garden as I'm calling it even if
the victory is gonna take a while to get
here I check it out we'll take a quick
break and be back after this we often
talk about the many different ways that
big banks take advantage of their
customers and one of our sponsors today
is current which is an online bank for
those of us who were sick of dealing
with all of the fees and the nonsense
from the big banks I use current myself
if you're watching this on YouTube
here's my actual current debit card
I'm holding up no minimum balance they
have 24/7 support no overdraft fees up
to $100 and it won't get declined no ATM
fees you can use over 55,000 ATMs
nationwide and unlike other banks you
receive your direct deposits instantly
which means you'll get paid by your
employer up to 2 days sooner you can
deposit checks instantly using your
camera phone and unlike other banks
current instantly refunds the hold on
your card from pumping gas you can pause
your debit card instantly also really
useful in many situations there are just
so many different advantages to ditching
the big banks and instead use a bank
that puts their members first it takes 2
minutes to sign up they'll immediately
ship you your debit card for free go
ahead and get started by clicking the
link down below the video